all right good morning everybody 9:00
welcome to drill
car there's represent resentative
Schmidt so we have a
quorum and represent hacken Phillips you
meeting all right Senator Ward moves to
accept
the minutes the previous meeting is
there a second second by represent
comments all right seeing none those in
favor
opposed okay we go and the consent
agenda is there anything to be removed
from
consent none I move the consent second
okay move by representative Schmidt
second by representative
Lynn any comments
opposed the first three items on the
regular
agenda have been asked to um be postpone
owned by the
agency uh the the third one the board of
home inspectors needs a waiver as well
because I apologize Madam chair um the
first item 20
2397 that item they're actually asking
to be moved till March because the board
does not meet until February 16th so
that one if it is accepted would need a
waiver as
well thank you for that clarification so
the
the motion would be to
postpone item a to the March meeting and
request a waiver and postpone B and C to
the February meeting and C need also
needs a waiver of its deadline that is
my motion thank you representative schm
any discussion comments
questions all right those in favor I I
those opposed all right madam chair I
don't believe there was a second
representative Lynn
second I thought I heard representative
Lynn but I could be
right yes you
did all right Senator gray you're
sitting in for Senator Lang who doesn't
Services so this proposal has one sort
of minor issue it's a a very broad
citation and um think we think for
clarity purposes it should be a more
specific citation but I think that the
fix for this is just an oral CA just to
say what citation to change it to so
that's my
suggestion okay uh good morning Nicole
Valena rules coordin Ator for the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh yes that's correct we uh it was a
misunderstanding on my part I had
responded and saying yes we could make
that edit I didn't submit I thought it
was an edit not a conditional approval
request so if you will allow that I will
do
that okay any questions from the
committee a motion um I can move a
conditional approval um citing HW um
5022 um in as noted by the
attorneys second okay any any further
any discussion questions or
comments those in favor I
opposed okay Board of mental health
practice okay this item was postponed
from the last meeting um because there
had been some testimonies submitted from
the New Hampshire Behavioral Health
Association and the committee felt that
the um that the board needed to revisit
um that the letters that were submitted
and to um consider maybe making some
changes to the rule um there is linked
on our website an amended um the an
amended conditional approval request it
may be titled a revised conditional
approval request but if you look on the
third page of the linked PDF you will
see that the board has made some changes
there um the association had had um
stated that they felt that the required
um hours 4,000 hours couldn't be met
within um well one they misunderstood
the rule they thought that that um the
maximum that was allowed was 2,000 hours
but the rule in fact does say a minimum
and um and then they also felt that that
the rule forced people to get those
required hours within um 2year time
period but that's not what the rule said
um the board has tweaked the rule a
little bit to address those issues and
and I think it it's fine if you look
there on like I said on page three of
the linked PDF they've changed that to
be clear that it that the 4 hours 4,000
hours have to be completed within 2
years but no more than 4 years so I
think that's a little clear and then I
believe um also on the next page they
made the same change so um with that I
have no other issues there are a couple
other editorial comments but I had
nothing else on this
proposal
okay thank you madam chair members of
the committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director office of professional ice
Insurance certification so I will
address um the the stakeholder concerns
and then I'll defer um to a r making
coordinator as well as the board chair
who's present regarding any other
changes the board has made um I did have
a lengthy conversation with the
stakeholder who had concerns with this
rule to get a better understanding of
what the concerns were and it appears
that the concerns really stem from a
misunderstanding of the enabling statute
um that allows this rule to move forward
so if you may recall I think it was back
in 2019 legislative session um the
legislature established additional
license types for for the board of
mental health practice um two of those
license types were to establish add
different additional categories licensed
Social Work associate for those educated
at the associate um degree level um
licensed social worker for those
educated with a b balarat and then the
statute also established conditional
licenses which are the license types
that were at issue or brought forward
with the stakeholder concerns so several
other states have a fourth category of
lure which is a non-clinical category of
lure for Master's educated um
individuals Vermont is is one of those
States um and there was some confusion
that the conditional license the the
enabling statute establishing the
conditional licenses was establishing
that fourth category and so with the
misunderstanding that essentially this
would be a permanent license for
non-clinical work at the Master's level
they had concerns with essentially the
4year cap on having that license um I
think we Now understand that the statute
did not establish that category um and
that that if they do wish to move
forward with establishing that category
that they're um they need to do so
legislatively so that's kind of the gist
of um the stakeholder
concerns I'd be happy to answer any
questions and i' defer if if I
understand correctly from some other
legislation in process the conditional
license is so that a person who has
graduated but is getting their
supervised practice has a license so
that they can independently bill that's
correct at least Bill somebody yes
that's
you
good morning Tina Kelly rules
coordinator for
oplc if you have any other questions I'd
okay think you've answered all our
questions thank you all right do we have
a
second discussion questions
comments those in favor I
opposed okay thank you very
Council so this was also a proposal that
was um postponed from the last meeting
and there's a conditional approval that
was sent in and there seems to only be
one remaining issue it's on page
35 and it's essentially the the
deadlines that the agency is setting do
not comply with 541a 29 and so that's
now good morning good morning my name is
Mark elano I attorney general turn the
mic on please I'm sorry thank you I'm
better than that generally uh good
morning my my name is Mark Delano I'm an
Assistant Attorney General from the
Department of Justice and I represent
the water
Council uh there are actually two issues
on in the conditional approval that
appear to be uh left in from comments
from uh legislative Services we'll deal
with the first one on
33 uh
firstly that
comment uh states that uh that the the
rule on declaratory rulings must comply
with RSA 541
a29 the the language of RSA uh 541 a29
in fact exempts declaratory rulings from
the
statute we wrote a letter to uh
legislative Services regarding this
issue and uh we never received a
response other than finding ourselves on
okay I did not receive that letter but I
I see what you're saying now in the rule
about declaratory ruling we we would
have changed that comment if we had seen
that now one thing to just mention here
as well is that the water Council rules
are the same uh with some minor changes
that are water Council specific to the
rules for the other three environmental
councils so the air Resources Council
the waste management Council and the uh
uh Wetlands Council uh these rules are
for the most part uniform across all of
them so some of these changes for
instance the one that was suggested on
page 33 was never suggested in either of
the three prior uh versions of the other
council's rules but otherwise are
materially the same uh the other comment
that remained is on page uh 32 Madam
chair just yes to on that one make sure
that you guys do forward a letter to
them that they didn't receive so their
records are complete absolutely I
brought a copy with me today appreciate
that on page 32 on page 32 uh on item D
and this is uh
ECW uh
217d uh we had suggested um well first
off legislative Services had crossed out
the May and asked us to insert sha the
other three Council rules have May and
the reason why we would prefer a May
there than a shall is because this is a
removal provision the presiding officer
can remove Council for a party at one of
these hearings uh but we want that to be
a permissive removal not a mandatory
removal and so our suggested change was
to go from they said shall we said is
authorized to and that would a departure
from the May language that's in the
rules thank you um
comment would note that the language
that was suggested is equivalent to
saying May is when you say is authorized
to right well I think that
the subcategories one and two look like
the criteria for a removal and therefore
May would would be not unreasonable in
my opinion agree I I believe I've looked
at this Rule and some of the other ones
that they've brought forward before and
I think that's where the committee had
landed on that particular issue and I
believe on um on the other issue on
declaratory judgments that um like
Christina said if we had seen that then
that would have been we would have
removed that
comment okay any other questions
comments concerns
do we have a motion I'd like to move the
question so you're moving to approve the
rule thank you sorry moving trouble
second okay discussion comment those in
favor I
opposed okay thank you very much I'm
Agriculture
so 2023 243 is an agricultural role on
acquisition of agricultural land
development rights and um there are
still a
few um issues with the rule starting on
page two there's a rule that requires
filing an application with the committee
and municipality and then later it needs
to be with the agent and so there it
just needs to be more consistency there
so a person knows where they're filing
and with who um there's a few places
where the the wording is just unclear
it's just unclear as written and should
be changed that's on page four and five
and on page
12 um page six there's deadlines that
don't comply with um 541
a29 um and on page eight there's some uh
subjective language that we would like
changed um because subjective Lang
ORS commissioner yeah this could have
been fixed probably with a conditional
approval so I'm sorry I said this these
these issues could have been fixed with
a conditional approval okay thank
you uh good morning this is Patricia
Benner for um I'm the legislative
coordinator for the Department of
Agriculture um and I apologize for uh
not having the conditional approval um
in time um I think there there wasn't
much turnaround from receiving
committee's uh comments but we are
working on correcting those issues and
clarifying some of the um um ambiguity
in the new
rule um should we postpone dealing with
this until you have the had the
opportunity you complet it well thank
you and um for the record Sean Jasper
commissioner of the department and um I
think we were a little unclear where we
were supposed to go with these changes
we have made suggested
changes um but didn't appear that there
was any place for us to submit them in
in time so we have the language but
um so I
been a long time since I sat on the
committee and things have changed and we
really weren't expecting this because we
were it was a read-option and obviously
these things were in the rules that had
uh previously been in place but okay I
don't know if you want to discuss what
we have suggested or
not a a postponement with a waiver would
would be in order and that would give us
time we can we can work with the agency
yes and please make sure that
that your
instructions on how to respond to
comments are clearer yes we'd hate to
have this happen again yes okay so um
Madam chair I'll motion and postponement
second le le on second okay thank you I
didn't hear you all right
it further discussion those in favor
I
post thank you and before you go we
might as well deal with the fact that
the previous rules have been expired for
15 years and I'm wondering what you've
done since then we have not purchased
any properties since then because we had
no money and that's why they were
allowed to to expire I will um let you
let you know that um right now there's a
statutory change and we weren't in
anticipating that these rules would
necessarily be used because we'll be
working with other organizations however
we've had some pretty exciting news to
us that a land owner in uh Dublin where
we do hold current easements wants to
make a
donation um of additional land so the
rules are going to be necessar even
though there's not going to be any uh
money exchanged I think we'll still need
to use to have this donation so they're
looking to to move forward uh and guess
we can't do anything till we get that
and the committee um is being
reconstituted and at the next GNC the
the um new newest members of the
committee will be appointed and we'll be
back up and and running so apologize
that we had some some confusion about
what was going on here and um okay well
I'm glad to know that the you haven't
been enforcing expir rules no
right good morning Senator gray you're
game so this rule is 2023 248 licenses
and permits and I actually the the
agency did a great job at um responding
to my comments so there's only one issue
which I think is solved because it's a
typo on the there's there's a typo on
the revision note of one of the forms
and I think you guys fixed that right so
then I have no more no more
comments
okay good morning I'm Marty Mobley I'm
the Le coordinator for fishing game and
and with me today hi good morning my
name is Jessica wheelan I'm the
licensing supervisor for fishing
game we recently had a new
um website uh instituted and so we put
all of our licensing forms online so the
vast majority of the changes we're doing
is to add the link to the online
licenses um and there were a couple of
other updates to go along with we
updated some Wildlife rules that went
into effect in June so we needed to make
a couple of changes on some of our
licenses to include an additional Bear
Tag um and and a couple of other little
tweets but that's this is mostly just to
be consistent I didn't get the comments
I still haven't got the comments so I
would and I agree all of the uh comments
could have been addressed in a
conditional approval um but I did speak
with Christina last week and I got her
the form that I had neglected to uh
include in the Orin original final
proposal and then there is the typo that
that dis disagreed that I had put
zero there a problem
getting messages in and out of your
office I don't know but it seems like
there may be so we're going to go ahead
and go back and look at into that is
that I know what's going
on so if I understand you correctly the
you finally received the comments and
are willing to to make a conditional
approval request incorporating those
comments is that can I make a
conditional approval request I don't
think a conditional appr because the
only issue is on a form and so the form
just needs to be Ed
edited I think no I think it's the text
needs to be edited the form I think is
correct or I don't know I'd have to look
up I'd have to look if the text needs to
approval yeah I think I think because I
think it's the text that says 01 the
revised yeah and and the form says Madam
chair is a motion to approve uh pending
the uh incorporation of the comments
appropriate at this time I believe it
would be I move second pending
incorporation any further comments or
questions from the
committee okay those in favor I post all
right thank you very much and please uh
hope we can get the communication issue
straightened
right and me think oh that's we don't
have the water sa watercraft safety
rules yet correct that is correct we've
not received that response but the
agency has until February 5th to submit
that to us okay so no trouble and
[Music]
the home builders and uh contractors are
still talking with Dees about alteration
of terrain and not ready to talk to
us and this
petition
thank you madam chair um most of the
committee probably has not seen this
before but under RSA 541a for an
individual can petition an agency uh to
amend or adopt rules or repeal rules um
and under the committee's own rules um
an individual can or group can request
Jael car to petition the agency uh the
requirement for that is that they first
um petition the agency and be denied in
this instance um clients of Donald funin
have uh requested that they be able to
they apparently sell vacation homes um
right now the rules of uh doj require
that the packet of materials uh
regarding sales must be uh hard copy um
the request for the petition ask that
they be allowed to disseminate that
electronically um the AG the request is
in here also the AG's response when it
denied the petition um the AG's office
apparently feels and they're here I
believe uh that uh because of the
importance of such a sale that it's
better to have it in paper than
electronically that uh the potential
purchasers May pay more attention to a
copy is the agency here is AG here to
help yes please would' like to hear your
it courney Lockwood I'm a Staff attorney
at the Department of Environmental
Services uh I know nothing about this
we've heard nothing about this uh we
were here a few months ago when the Home
Builders Association uh sent the
committee a letter which we didn't
receive a copy of ahead of time um I
don't me I this is am I you're the wrong
person we're look at okay I'm sorry the
attorney generals
gotcha Dees as far as we know is still
office my name is JR Davis the
button
morning Madam chairman my name is J.R
Davis I'm an Assistant Attorney General
with the consumer protection and any
trust Bureau of the Department of
Justice attorney general's office uh we
are opposed to this proposed change
before I go through any of the details I
just want to make sure that the
committee has the benefit of the letter
that we transmitted electronically to
yesterday um I believe that's in our
pack the last one on a page of our
packet last three pages of our packet in
a the thicker packet contains both the
request uh from Mr fonstein and uh the
AG's response in a separate attachment
are the current uh Jus rules that uh the
to and I'm at the preference of the
committee whether you want us to go
explain the basis for for our objection
to the change of our longstanding rule
or to respond uh once the petitioners
attorney who I believe is present today
makes a presentation I leave it totally
first
um I think the petitioner oh the
petitioner's point is is pretty clear
we'd like to they just want to send it
electronically with the option for hard
copy and which we all understand so if
you could explain your opposition to
that idea C certainly uh just so it's
clear there's nothing under the and if
I'm too loud let me know because I'm not
used to using microphones um there's
nothing under our rules that prohibits
the
delivery uh of the public offering
statement
electronically there is something in our
rules that requires a hard
copy and we believe that that that is
fundamentally important so first off
from the standpoint of convenience to
the consumer there is nothing that Pro
prohibits electronic delivery of a
public offering statement or any of the
other solicita documents associated with
someone who's perspectively entering
into a purchase and sales agreement
regarding either a regulated subdivision
or a regulated condominium the reason I
say regulated as I'm sure the members of
the committee is aware not all
subdivisions are regulated by the bureau
not all Condominiums are regulated by
the
bureau depends upon whether it's
residential only or whether there's a
certain number of units
um the reason or reasons that the bureau
is steadfastly opposed to this proposed
change is
because the general court has given our
Bureau charge of protecting consumers in
a very
complicated legal mindfield area of
law
normally all things being equal there
are very few areas of New Hampshire
Commerce that are as
regulated and as prescribed
statutorily as land transactions
involving developments of subdivisions
all things being equal with certain
exceptions for fraud and the
transactions involving the sell of
Securities and certain Insurance
provisions and certain Provisions
regarding transfer of automobiles the
statutes by and large adopt some version
of caveat mtor let the buyer
beware because of the concern that this
General Court had and I believe still
has regarding the prospect for
Consumer
Fraud consumer
misunderstanding consumer
confusion and people not knowing what it
is they're buying when they're spending
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars in purchasing what might just be
a one-week rental but most of the time
and quite often involves their home
place and for that reason the eneral
Court specified in both RSA chapter 356a
dealing with
subdivisions and RSA 360 excuse me 356b
Condominiums mandatory requirement in
the vast majority of cases of a public
offering statement and the public
offering statement as that phrase is
used in both statutes is similar to the
concept of a perspectus whenever someone
is looking to invest and financi cial
instrument stock Bond debenture
whatever the statute is very clear as to
what has to be in those public offering
statements the statutes are very clear
that the Attorney General's office has
to actually approve them and actually
designates the form that they should be
in so that you can take a public
offering statement from one condominium
and another one and although they will
not be identical language because the
projects will be different there will
there is a general format in which what
gets disclosed in what order all based
upon requirements that are contained in
the
statute the concern that the bureau has
is not to be quite honest with the
petitioner if Riverwalk was the only
entity that was developing promoting and
selling Condominiums and subdivisions
within the state of New Hampshire we
wouldn't need the
regulation but Riverwalk is not the only
entity they are but one of hundreds of
entities if not thousands of entities
that develop promote and sell new
condominium projects and new
subdivisions and the Condominiums again
can either be
full-time or some version of integral
ownership and River walks project is
both our concern is is that although
there are consumers who have computers
or other tablets of sufficient size to
be able to download and be able to
meaningfully read and
review these detailed single pay lined
legal documents we think that is the
exception to the rule we already know
from our previous experience in the
bureau and again we're the agency that
receives most consumer complaints
regarding the conduct of business within
the
state we already know that there has
been a plethora of problems with people
receiving electronic disclosures only
regarding important contracts and legal
documents we have no problem with
electronic disclosure we think for
people who want it it's great but we
think that everyone ought to have and
ought not have the ability to opt out of
the physical copy now I've brought for
the benefit of the
committee copies of river walk's last
approved public offering statement not
the numerous documents that are attached
to it that would end up making it about
three pages thick but the actual
narrative description with the
permission of the chairman I would hand
those
out not knowing whether all the members
of the committee have actually ever
condominium not all of us have
direct and I want to correct my letter I
said it was 18 Pages plus the index the
index is included in the 18 Pages oh
type this is an excellently
prepared and my opinion and I was not
the attorney who reviewed this so I'm
not saying I did a good job someone else
did a good job in approving it but
someone did an excellent job in writing
it and this public offering statement
starts off after the cover sheet in the
very first page there's two statutorily
required
disclosures that our Bureau requires
that we implement but that the
legislature is required first is the
disclosure of how important the public
offering statement is you will note that
it's in capitals and it's in bold
the statute authorizing public offering
statements does not allow variations in
the type unless the Attorney General's
office requires
it we think it's so important right up
front for people to know this document
is the big
cheese you better read this as carefully
if not more carefully than the purchase
and sales agreement because most of the
time with the purchase and sales
agreement it's what's the price when's
the closing and what are the add-ons and
then a whole lot of other stuff that can
become important but most of the time
aren't but everything involving a
condominium is complicated it is a
pickup stick for those of you who are
old enough to remember that game of
legal rights and are very complicated
and no two Condominiums are created
equally or the
same the actual operation of a
condominium varies greatly and
significantly from one condominium
project to the to the other between
who's responsible for what what are the
common areas those are the areas that
are owned jointly what are the limited
common areas who's responsible for
maintaining them what things can be done
on them the purpose of the disclosure
statement is so that people can
understand for the particular
condominium they're looking and
purchasing and spending thousands of
dollars on if not hundreds of thousands
of dollars what they're
getting our concern is is that from our
experience already particularly in
automobile sales and other items where
there's often sales that have been
moving towards electronic primary or
often electronic
only transmission is that it is far too
easy for even the well- intending
consumer to
receive an electronic bundle that's
going to have these 18 Pages plus the
hundreds of pages of attach M
ments on their cell
phone and I've seen this happen when
I've been at automobile dealers buying
cars myself or when I in my prior prior
Private Practice represented automobile
dealers see people reading a 10 or 12
page very detailed retail installment
contract or attempting to read it by
scrolling and in
terbly after they get the name and they
check the price the next thing they do
is where is the the place where I say
I've signed it and I initial
it in my private practice and I was a
long-term attorney I have difficulty
seeing Justice Lynn without a black Rob
on
so it took me a while to be realizing
that I could actually sit down um but
but I've seen this in my own private
practice practice where people bought
things and they were told hey yeah
that's the legal mumbo jumbo it's not
important and they sign it and once
they've signed it
electronically once they've said yes
there is a five-day ride of recision by
Statute for Condominiums and regulated
land cells but the five-day ride of
recision is only meaningful if you know
you need to look into what it is you
said yes to and if you've been convinced
either by your own unfortunately
laziness or busyness or you don't have
good access to a computer like the
transcriptionist has to where you can
actually read
it and come back to it then we're making
a mockery of protecting
consumers this will never be a concern
with
Riverwalk if as I said earlier and I
meant it if the people who operate river
rock or if everyone in the condominium
industry was of the same caliber we
wouldn't need regulation but I can tell
you we know that that's just not
true we receive complaints regularly
regarding concerns regarding what's
going on in condominium units I know the
board the the legislature is aware
there's several bills right now one
involving the possibility of
adopting establishing a board to deal
with condominium disputes between unit
boards we just think it is a mistake if
we're going to be serious about
protecting
people in a very detailed complicated
legal
transaction by encouraging them or
allowing them to do electronic
only there's nothing that prevents this
developer or any other developer from
making electronic disclosure of
everything so long as the consumer
conser still gets a hard copy of their
purchase and sales agreement and of
statement even the public offering
statement says how important it is to
read it all the way through suggest
making sure you understand the
attachments and recommends talking to an
attorney because these are hundreds of
thousands of dollars of transactions per
consumer typically
and once you've said yes unless you
realize there's a problem within the
5-day recision period you're stuck
whether you understood or
not so if our Bureau is going to
actually live up to its name consumer
protection if we're going to follow the
Mandate that the legislature gave us in
both statute to enforce and administer
for the protection of the
consumers the
statutes we believe that there still
needs to be inhand delivery we don't
care if it's by mail we don't care how
it
is now some people will say well that
time real estate transactions seldom
close that quickly so it's not that much
more time for
delivery it amazes me that there is this
thing called ups that has overnight
delivery and it works very
well I know I've been using it for 30
practice most but not all of these
transactions involve some FaceTime
between with the
consumer so we just don't get how it
will be so burdensome on either
consumers or developers to continue to
require what our regulations have
required since the very first passage of
both of these statutes if committee
members have any questions I would be
glad to attempt to answer them and if we
need a translator perhaps we can get
someone to help me because I'm from
Southwest New
Hampshire Senator L you had a question
yeah just a couple questions so is is
there an a specific statute that says it
has to be hard copy or is that just
administrative
rules that's just in our regulations the
statute merely says it has to be
delivered when both stat statutes were
written there was no such thing as
electronic delivery unless you were the
government um or very wealthy
corporations follow follow so again
given the Advent of technology and
everything you can do with technology
being a technologist myself yeah things
like docy sign you can make them initial
every single page to make sure they've
seen it and adopted it and readed it and
and keep that as a transaction to show
that the consumer or the person who who
signing the docy sign document um read
everything or at least initialing the
page saying they've looked at it why
would that actually I think that would
probably be a better consumer protection
because you mail somebody a document you
have no no idea if it went straight in a
trash can or if they actually looked at
it where with an electronic means you
can actually require that every page
gets an initial and that both both
parties know that they initialed it um
wouldn't that be a better consumer
protection than just mailing and firing
and
forgetting I was
confident I even thought it was more
likely than not that the mere fact that
someone has to push the initial button
on a doc assign document on whether it's
one page or every page I would say yes I
know from my experience as a private
attorney and I know based upon the
experience being at the bureau and the
complaints received that unfortunately a
lot of people stop reading after about
the first second page when they're doing
electronically technologist people are
used to using computers people who have
full-size
screens May well be a horse of different
color as they said in the Wizard of ox
we have to
regulate not because we have no ability
to distinguish
between the
honorable
intelligent scrupulous developer like
Riverwalk and others we s similar do not
have the ability to write regulations
for sophisticated
Savvy consumers who are used to using
computers for legal documents and are
used to reviewing legal documents as
opposed to those who I can't be bothered
now someone could say well what about
that we can't help people who won't help
themselves we shouldn't create a system
where it's easy for people to not know
what doing and buying and selling a
condominium most importantly in this
case buying a condominium in a new
development because the this all has to
do with new
developments is not something that most
people are familiar with and it is
fraught with legal problems and
financial problems I know this because I
used to do it in private practice I know
this because since I've been at the
bureau because of my previous experience
I've been doing a lot of condominium
work and unfortunately a lot of it's not
just been
regulation approval of new Condominiums
a lot of it has been workouts and
problems with condominiums that e have
either gone South or are going south or
are having major disputes with the
Condominium Association because what was
promised Le verbally doesn't appear to
be what the reality is that's why we
think a hard copy is the best way to go
for you
unnecessary but I I don't know how we
could come up with
words or regulation would allow us
distinguish between the informed
consumer and The Savvy consumer a
fundamental principle of consumer
protection work both on a state level
and a federal level is that we look at
the typical and average consumer in
adopting
regulations for that reason we think
that re requiring the hard copy is
important no one has to use
it follow follow so again I I guess my
question comes around right now I'm
assuming if they send it by mail there's
some all they do is they get a return
receipt the person sign for it but you
have no no idea whether they actually
opened it or threw it in the trash can
none it is no consumer protection around
that just the the the Riverwalk in this
case would just say oh no we sent it
here's my verification and that was it
it would just be the green return from
the from the post office correct the
process is that the bureau will never
know unless there's a dispute the the
the developer is required to keep a copy
of the signed
acknowledgement the bureau that green
receipt from the post office no the
actual the the public offering statement
actually includes an acknowledgment of
receipt and and that's included on on
all um public offering statements now
some some developers do do the initial
on the bottom of the page things um we
don't require
that we take people at their word if
they if they said they got it they got
it we can't make them read it we can
encourage it make sure it says it on the
first page and it says it more than one
place in it that it should be read all
the information that we have regarding
condominiums on our website and we have
very ious places for informed consumers
to look and see you know what you should
look into things to be aware of we
always say read the public offering
statement if you do nothing else um but
we can't make anyone do
thatone else have a question concern
representative Leon and then
representative Schmid thank you madam
chair and thank you for coming with all
this knowledge of this um one of my
other con questions and concerns is
around what's going to happen with
somebody um if they pass away and it's
only on their computer that nobody can
access and what their errors will do
with the paper copy I mean obviously we
can't say that the person will file it
in a real file cabinet instead of the
circular file but it gives a I would
think that it would that would give a
greater likelihood that there will be a
copy available to those who survive the
one who's
Contracting I'm somewhat of a
neanderthal on this point so I will
readily acknowledge that if I was
receiving something electronically only
and if I was receiving on my personal
device as opposed to my work device
where I have a meaningful file system
even if it was still on the device it
would probably be not particularly
readily accessible after
about three months more or less six
months or a
year but I may be behind the learning
curve on that because I still hand my
cell phone to my children whenever I
want to learn how to do something
new representative Schmidt you had a had
a
question well it's a small matter but
you're not only being recorded you're
being videotaped and you're operating
under false pretenses because the S sign
in front of you references your your
colleague who was before us about half
an hour he's smarter and better looking
than I am
too I won't comment on either one of
those but you have a question
representative the question was whether
he would like to remove that since he's
being recorded
ah we he answered it any other questions
Senator GR um I I think we have a case
here where we've got the statute and
we're kind of being asked to do
committee work okay on the thing what
what we need happen is
for our our staff uh to tell us where we
are and if a legislative fix is needed
you know have the department work with
the legislature of their choice to get
this done so it it seems to me that the
it's just a matter of interpretation of
delivery of documents
and the agency has interpreted it in one
particular way and some stakeholder
disagrees with that interpretation
that's
it's Madam chairman if I could just
briefly interject on that point although
we do believe the committee should
reject this petion and deny it we have
suggested in our letter that the if if
the committee is thinking that it might
move favorably on the petition we have
requested pursuant to the administrative
procedures act in our letter that this
committee consider making a referral to
the Commerce Committee which normally
handles condominium matters and there's
also a special committee that is formed
under RSA 356b colon 70 and do uh
regarding legislative and Regulatory
matters for condominium we've suggested
that if this committee
is tending positive regarding the
petition that perhaps it would be
appropriate to have the expertise of
those committees but we leave that to
the Defence of the commit here
representative ly yeah so I was just
going to say um I I'm assuming that that
um the the there's a representative here
who brought the petition um and I I mean
so I assume we're going to hear from
that person I guess what I the only
comment I would make is obviously I want
to I think we all would want to hear
what the what
the the prop opponent of this change is
but my only my only comment uh is I I
think you've made a very persuasive
argument the only the only comment I
would make is you know if the my sense
is if this that rep that what Senator
Lang um suggested um I think is I think
is it's a it's a his point is very well
taken the problem I have is that I think
you know if you were proposing if the
partitioners were proposing this change
10 years from now 10 years in the future
maybe it would make more sense but my
sense is that you really are right on in
terms of the way people nowadays
including you know neanderthals like of
my age uh who you know deal with
electronic things I think we are much
more careful um in dealing with things
that are hard copies than than we do
things that are done electronically and
I'm not sure that it's limited to people
that are my age but certainly it it uh
it's true of people that are you know
probably over 50 or 60 um and so for
those reasons I I think we should not
make any change I think your your
position is very well
taken okay director moral um early in
the testimony from uh assistant AG Davis
he indicated that there was no
prohibition to have an electronic copy
in addition to the uh hard copy um you
have a two-page attachment that contains
the current Jus rule rules on this uh
both on the first page in
130701 and on the second page in
140601 um it indic it specifies how this
is done and the requirements for uh
submitting this um I don't disagree that
perhaps an entity could get an
electronic copy but I do not believe
from reading this and I've read it
carefully that a read would understand
that that is
available uh paragraph C does talk about
a waiver but that waiver is only as to
paper just for clarification I I don't
want to suggest that the regulation says
and oh by the way you can send an
electronic copy but they can because
there's nothing prohibits it no it
happens occasionally we have developers
who say we want to do this as part of
our marketing is is this okay and I'll
say yes and I'll say I'll give you an
email so you don't have to worry about
it but I know I can represent to the
committee that a lot of declarants
transmit the documents that way but they
still make sure that the public offering
statement and the purchase and sales
agreement there's a hard well actually
we don't require a hard copy on the
purchase sales agreement but they often
do them together
because they have co- receipts on them
yes I I think
that if I were reading this I would not
take a electronic delivery as an option
or even uh something that could be done
so I
would I would request that you revise
the rule to say that for information
only you could a an electronic copy is
is allowable and even
encouraged I don't think that have
authority to say that I know we could do
that but I have authority to be able to
tell you I could well imagine that as
part of our next Ru making we would be
doing that but I can tell the committee
right now I know it happens without even
being asked every time I get the
question from a declarant that's the
person who's doing the de the uh
condominium attorney I say oh yeah of
course do you want an email just so you
know but yeah I mean I I agree with you
I don't think we want people trying to
read this thing on their phones uh I'd
go blind but um
but the electronic
form you know can be can be used and and
then you just keep the hard copy in your
paper files which are probably less
voluminous than your computer files
these days and and just so it's clear to
the extent that I haven't been Bureau
has no concern with electronic delivery
of important documents Our concern
is this particular document the public
offering statement is really
the be all of the be's needs regarding
what you need to know at a minimum
before you invest your money and our
concern is is electronic
only clarification yes so clar
clarifying on that so if someone like
Riverwalk wanted to do they could send
out the hard copy could they also send
out a digital copy they get a digital
signature and if they got the digital
signature would meet the needs of the a
of the
organization
that I have to look at the comparison of
our electronic signature
statue and our
regulations I can't answer the question
because I'm not sure how they coales
right now we would have no problem with
conceptually unless it's in our regs
that I'm not aware of and I don't think
it is we don't have a problem with
electronic
signatures purchase and sales agreements
on
condominium uh purchases are often done
electronically our problem Our concern
is is that the consumer not have a hard
copy of the purchase and sales agreement
again we acknowledge they may read it or
may not but but we think that the
likelihood that they read it were at
least skim it enough to where they oh I
ought to know about that is greater if
it's in paper than if it's
electronically across the board no for
every consumer absolutely not some won't
read and some will read the electronic
excellent last followup so again again
the compromise is it could be both so
you could use a hard copy to meet the
requirement of sending a hard copy but
get the signature digitally um through
another another means that has the same
exact
document yes and I think that might be
happening now it just the reason I say
it might be happening now the way this
process works just from a practical
standpoint is Riverwalk comes in there
whether it's the brand new project or
they're adding units or adding they have
a proposal we review the new P public
offering statement as you can see on the
one that I that I sent you you know this
has been edited over time as they as
their project has changed we approve it
they have to use
it we never know
what's happening unless there's a
complaint
file
so as a practical matter I know that
there's a lot of developers who do
electronic signatures I'm assuming
they're doing them on both the per the
purchase of sales agreement and the
public offering statement but I don't
know that for a fact because we only
find out about these things whenever
there's a problem I haven't heard of a
problem with people saying I didn't sign
the document I have had problems we have
had problems problems not just J.R Davis
the bureau has had problems with
consumers saying I signed stuff
electronically and I didn't realize what
was in it but both in the condominium
world in the automobile world and in a
whole host of other ones but the
automobiles are the one we see the most
because that's one of the industries
that certain dealerships it's nearly
it's very problematic to get anything in
paper previous to signing okay
representative hacken Phillips thank you
thanks Madam chair I um could not agree
more with u Mr Davis about this matter
as a practicing attorney in this
specific field I've represented both
developers senior citizens who have sold
and purchased Condominiums and I've also
handled some litigation over condominium
um enforcement of bylaws so um I think
that this paper copy is critical I think
especially with the generation folks who
do not have computers do not have email
addresses do not use electronic means of
communications other than telephones you
know landlines so I think it there are
still people in our state who absolutely
require paper copies
so I agree with you um also the industry
is also making use of electronic data um
communication and you know but with the
agreement up front that they're willing
to do the docy sign situation but it
doesn't prevent I mean the developers
are still required to send this
documentation which is a minimal
expenditure for these folks who are
already deep in the woods you know
trying to invest these you know get
these Investments out and out the door
make money on their project so um I'm
sure that the representative here who is
going to talk on behalf of Lon Mountain
LLC will make mention of the expenditure
that they're probably trying to avoid by
having this electronic means but um I
think you know it's a minor
inconvenience for the seller and I think
it's important to maintain for Consumer
Protections so I would like to just go
ahead and make a motion to decline the
the petition I think it's
unnecessary okay is there a second that
motion second by Senator
Ward any Madam chair yes we do have a
representative uh for the petitioner
present yes we're going to deny it
coming yes that's a good point M Madam
chairman before before we go to the next
part just one thing the you you made a
suggestion about us thinking about
amending our rule one thing that I do
let need to let the committee KN know is
when I go back to my chief and we talk
about this one thing we will have to
think through is
timing because the statute says that the
five Day statutory right of recision is
based upon the latter of the signature
of the purchase and sales agreement or
the
delivery of the um public offering
statement and so if we had different
deliveries electronically on one date
delivery by hand on another date I don't
want to get into a situation where I've
created a statutory ambiguity so we in
the process of doing that it would
probably be a situation where we'd have
to have the timing be for whatever the
loudest of those three dates were unless
there was an amendment to the statute
okay thank you that's a I just didn't
want to create a you know we don't
either um if you could let the
petitioner
morning I appreciate your time thank you
all I know we have a pending motion on
the table so I'll be brief I know that
attorney uh good morning Caroline
Leonard uh I'm attorney with Gallagher
Calahan garell and I'm here on behalf of
my client Riverwalk at Lon Mountain
LLC I have with me this giant stack of
documents I know you guys all just
received thank you attorney Davis uh the
18-page narrative summary of the public
offering statement but what attorney
Davis mentioned but I wanted to give you
the actual visual is this is the entire
public offering statement under the
statute for both the land sale
disclosures Act and the Condominium Act
which governs subdivisions and
condominium sales we are required
developers are required to include a lot
of different things as attorney Davis
alluded to in this document this is how
big it is 47 Pages um that's not to say
every Resort has something this
extensive Riverwalk is a more
complicated Resort in my opinion um but
I just wanted to give you guys a flavor
for this is what we're talking about um
every single consumer needs to receive
all of this not just the 18 Pages
attorney Davis shared with you all of
this and these include the statutorily
required components so to touch on an
earlier point about this notion of
whether we go in the legislative
direction of amending a bill or creating
a bill or if we are here during our
regulatory phase this aspect requiring
physical paper delivery is mandated
through the regulations it's not part of
the statute as such I would encourage
the committee to address this in its
opice under its opes as the ability to
effectuate rule changing um I want to
give you a little bit lay of the land as
far as how these are done in other
jurisdictions um I also have the
pleasure of representing uh the American
Resort Development Association Arda they
are an association as the name is
suggest of various different um
developers around the country of resorts
I've been working with them on this in
addition to our client Riverwalk and
they shared with me that in every major
State around the country that sells
times share condominium they permit
electronic delivery we are behind the
times in New Hampshire and I really
think to touch on Senator Lang's point
this we could very readily accomplish a
protective mechanism that permitted both
electronic or paper delivery and if you
read our suggested change that's
actually what we're proposing we're not
suggesting only electronic we're
suggesting give the consumer the choice
if the consumer feels I'm not
comfortable reading something this big
in electronic form I'd really like a
paper copy great we will provide you one
free of charge no problem we can build
to that end but right now the regulation
does not allow that it dictates mandates
paper only I say let the consumer decide
we don't need to be paternalistic we
don't need to make this choice for the
consumer
you all know the benefits of electronic
delivery you can search you can do
contrl F if you want to find a specific
section on say dos if I have to hunt
through this physical copy that's going
to take me ages if I can just do a
search quickly with my keyboard I'm much
more likely to find that quickly um you
all know the the ability if you wanted
to increase the font size if you wanted
for example to translate the document if
English might not be your first language
there are a host of different reasons
why electronic really affords the
consumer I think more protection I say
give the consumers the choice um our
revised language we hope strikes this
balance between
efficiency better protection and an
ability to if a consumer wants it they
can still have paper we're not disputing
that if somebody wants paper they can
have it um and I believe I heard a
question earlier about uh if somebody
wanted to review the actual document in
physical form the statute actually
already mandates that a resort always
keep a desk copy of the current
iteration of the public offering
statement on site so I I think
representative Leon it was your question
as to an heir if if for example a
beneficiary or a relative uh knew that
their parent or the deceased had had
ownership at a particular Resort they
could easily contact the resort and
again I know I can only speak to my
developer clients but um we are very
happy to always accommodate such a
request um we can send it electronically
but we always by by law we are required
to keep a copy of this document at all
times at the front desk so if that helps
alleviate concerns I wanted to make sure
we hit that as well I'm happy to answer
any questions okay thank you are there
any questions representative Lynn I
wonder if you could tell us that you
said that that the the for this
condominium it's 400 Pages or something
could you give us some idea of I assume
you've represented other condominium
Developers of sort of the average is
that what the average uh documentation
is your honor I'm going I'm apologize
for calling you your honor I'm still
going to tab it um uh I'm GNA give you
the lawyer answer it really depends um
it depends on the type of product
they're selling um if for example
they're only selling Whole condominium
units it might be a little bit shorter
if for example like this Resort they're
selling interval interests meaning
somebody could own for a week somebody
could own for a few months uh that
requires additional paperwork because
you have to provide each type of
ownership's corresponding paperwork
that's a very long answer to your
question thank
questions
okay thank you for the information
appreciate
it so we have a motion to deny the
petition the the request for a petition
is
any further comments questions concerns
representative Lon um thank you madam
chairman I think that this is a more
complex issue and I'm I'm thinking it
may make sense to deny the petition and
go through the legislative process and
I'm sorry if I missed any comments to
the to the similar when I needed to run
out for a
moment yes I would believe if
representative hacket Phillips wishes to
amend her um her motion to include a
reference to the
legislature I would certainly I hope
that we could accept that the committee
is feeling that way that's fine with
me I I'll second the amended motion okay
comments okay those in favor of denying
the request for petition and referring
it to the legislature say I I I those
opposed
I thank you okay we will not P pursue
the
petition at this point we
will uh suggest that the committee on
condominium development or the Commerce
Committee deal with be this be brought
to the attention of those two
committees um Scott Eaton just pointed
out to me he is still a committee
attorney part-time uh
that when you voted on 2023 243 from
fishing game when you you voted to
postpone um it will need a
waiver oh it was okay my apologies I
thought there was
too okay never mind all right is there
any other
business all right thank you all we are
adjourned and we will not have a
continued
meeting
no
you're
aware
yeah